Okay,
personally,
today I'm in a very interesting
stereophonic Ka Ka Ka conversation,
uh,
in,
in one ear.
Alright,
I hear beautiful symphonic music.
It,
it comes from a person like a Gordon
Brown in the UK.
It comes from a person like,
uh,
the crown prince of Abu Dhabi who says I
want to build in Abu Dhabi where were,
were,
were today.
This the beginnings of an idea capital,
a full idea capital.
I talked to lead leaders like a Gordon
Brown and Sheikh Mohammed bin Zayed.
And I hear from them first of all that
they embraced the notion that the world
of the 21st century is going to be a
world of,
of ideas that that education and
education has the highest level.
It's going to be the key to unlocking
that and,
and that they see as the future of their
societies investing heavily on the
public sphere,
investing heavily in,
in,
in higher education and access to higher
education for,
for every talented student and,
and for system that builds to plus the
students as far up the talent,
talent pyramid as,
as,
as they can be pressed.
On the other hand here in the United
States,
I hear very,
very few of our political leaders
grasping that concept and dedicating
themselves to it.
You hear a person like Mike Bloomberg in
New York who,
uh,
it sees the fact that,
that maintaining New York as,
as one of the few idea capitals of the
world is key to the city's future and
building the infrastructure
educationally from kindergarten right
through the leading research
universities we have in the city is,
is pivotal to New York maintaining it's
positioned.
But,
but what you begin to see dangerously
is,
is most of our political leaders
actually on the other side of the
equation.
So in the other ear,
in the stereophonic world in which I
live in,
in the other ear,
I hear kind of grading a total music
coming from the political leadership,
uh,
in,
in the United States where,
where they've begun to demagogue around
issues of higher education.
So you hear a constant connection of,
of,
you know,
healthcare costs and the cost of higher
education.
A very simplistic,
appealing and the talking point message,
especially to the middle class for whom,
uh,
the higher education costs are all seem
to be skyrocketing.
And uh,
it,
it's very easy to run past the fact
that,
uh,
at,
at most of the great universities of
this country where tuition,
yes,
is going up,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's going up because of the pressure of
providing the kind of quality education
you have to provide the,
it's going up because the cost of books
and technology are going up.
It's going up because knowledge is
expanding and it's more to cover and
therefore you have to hire more faculty
to do.
And it's going up because every single
reform you want to make to provide a
better education as students to come to
you involves lowering the student
faculty ratio,
which means increasing your personnel
costs.
And universities are essentially when
you,
when you boil everything down,
essentially irreducibly,
they are socrates and the tree and the
student.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's the problem of the live string
quartet.
You know,
how the personnel intensive a system.
That's what a university is.
It's personal intensive faculty.
Students are,
if you,
if you have a live string quartet,
you don't,
you can't use technology,
you can't,
you can't take the music because then
it's not live.
You can't cut your personnel costs.
That is not a quartet,
a,
you can't play the music faster because
then it's not really the music.
And that's what we're in,
is engaged in,
in a high class education.
So,
so,
uh,
the politicians in the United States as
they,
as,
as they appealed glibly to the,
you know,
the cost of higher education,
I began to pound that which makes this
country very special.
I mean higher education is the pride of
this country.
If they act as if there's some kind of a
monopoly out there among the 6,500
actors in higher education,
diversity as we are,
that is involved in a conspiracy to
build the middleclass of their money.
You know,
this could not be more wrong and it
could not be more shortsighted.
So here I am in the stereophonic
conversation where outside the United
States people are getting the idea that
what,
what you need to have the,
the,
the future to own the future,
to be one of the idea capitals in this
matrix world of idea capitals.
You need great higher education.
And here in the United States we're in
the process of,
of,
of a devaluing that.
So we're in the process of,
in a world where we dominate today,
and I guess this isn't a good metaphor
to use given the present state of the
Yankees,
but I'll use it anyway speaking more to
the glory of the franchise.
Over time we're in the process of
turning the Yankees into the mud hens.
Well now the rest of the world is saying
we're,
we're going to create what you have and
if you look 25 and 50 years after,
it's a very dangerous world for the
United States.
How do you change that?
You change it by issuing the clarion
call,
uh,
to,
to the political leadership to begin to
take the long view.
Even though,
even though it may not be the
politically effect,
the view.